POI flowers are awesome not only do they
grant us freedom of movement with the
POI but also the spirograph likee
patterns that they create in midair are
absolutely gorgeous here are five levels
of these patterns to share with your
[Music]
friends Drex here from Drex Factor Poise
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we going to run
through po flowers at five different
difficulty levels but before we dive in
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark bunk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrro light toys
spinballs and Ultra PO for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the business friend of
the channel Becca Becken thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission to my mind POI flowers
are kind of like the schinger cat of poy
tricks on the one hand just
understanding what they are is quite
easy to do but being able to perform
them let alone perform them in all
timing and Direction modes yeah that's a
bit of a challenge and because flowers
are one of those poy tricks that we can
easily add different modules of other
POI Concepts onto I guarantee you that
there is a flower that will be a
challenge for you regardless of what
your skill level is so I'm going to go
ahead and walk you through five
different po flowers depending upon
skill level that I think might be a
great challenge for you starting with
level one beginner ins spin flowers in
together same so we are going to need to
have some understanding of the jargon
here in order to be able to navigate
this list first and foremost knowing our
timing and Direction modes together same
together opposite split opposite and
split Time same direction and also too
knowing the difference between our inpin
and our anti-spin flowers though I don't
always agree with it there's wide
consensus that inpin flowers are at
least a little bit easier to learn than
anti-spin flowers and that together same
is probably the most intuitive timing
and Direction mode after all it just
involves moving around the hands
together in parallel so this then brings
together the most intuitive and easiest
to learn elements of flowers into one
package and honestly I think I could
teach pretty much anybody how to do just
this one flower in 30 minutes or less
and of course it has to be said that
just because this is the simplest
version of flowers we can do that
doesn't mean that it has to be boring to
look at we can add some body movement
into it lunging back and forth we can
take it across the top and down around
with over curves and under curves there
are a lot of options here the limit here
is not on the PO trick but on the
imagination of the person performing it
so with our first flower we've taken a
look at the most basic modules of
Performing po flowers in general now
it's time to start adding on to them
level two beginner intermediate
fountains
I know we usually think of fountains as
being a derivative of three beat weaves
and waist straps but I think that we
ought to think of them as being a
derivative of flowers as well after all
we can clearly see how the hands and POI
are moving around in such a fashion that
we get concentric circles of various
types looking just like a spirograph the
only difference being that the POI and
hands are moving in different timing and
Direction modes but that just produces a
spicier pattern in the end right in
particular one of the things that I love
about fountains is that once you get
your was wraps down they're a pretty
easy next step to take all you have to
do is add the over and under parts to
them and voila you've got a flower once
again adding some body movement into
these flowers can really make them pop
I'm a big fan of using under curves and
over curves as you're performing these
fountains that way your body and hips
seem to follow the path of the POI and
your hands around in a big circle
awesome so at this point we have
something that is probably expected and
something that might be kind of
unexpected in terms of putting our
flowers together but there is one aspect
of flowers that we haven't played with
yet that I'd like to get to in our next
example trick number three intermediate
split opposites anti- spin flowers yeah
so I went back and forth a lot on
whether to do split time opposites or
split Time same direction I think in
many instances when we're thinking of
anti-spin flowers we're really thinking
of those in Split Time same direction
but split time opposites are just so
eye-catching when you get them down
there's something about that symmetry
going across a horizontal line that just
look looks incredible I honestly think
that part of it may just be that that
axis of symmetry runs counter to how the
human body does and so this becomes
really really interesting and kind of
asymmetric in the process what we really
get out of this flower is not just an
exotic timing and Direction mode but
also the first appearance of anti-spin
flowers in this list granted either one
of the previous flowers that we looked
at could have been anti-spin but this
was the one that I really wanted to
visit this was the last timing in
Direction mode that I learned how to
perform anti-spin flowers in and I have
to say that it's also the one that I go
back to most often in my own flow now I
think that there's just something
interesting and magical about this
particular version so it's the version
that I went with all right cool so now
that we've officially broken the
anti-spin ice it's time to throw a brand
new challenge at you and this one is
going to include a whole lot of modules
all stacked together trick number four
intermediate Advanced the anti-spin
Archer weave Fountain yeah so that's
really a mouthful isn't it like our
fountains this is a trick that involves
taking a weave and turning it into a
flower but we're also adding antipin
onto that and because it's an Archer
weave it's also a body Tracer Fountain
many of us learn how to do this in ins
spin but I'd be willing to bet that
fewer learn how to do it in anti-spin
and I personally think that the
anti-spin version is really the one that
pops it's also really counterintuitive
because you kind of have to reach across
your body in order to make the over and
under Parts work like going over I have
to take my left hand from under and
going under I have to take my right hand
from over it's really weird and a little
uncomfortable but goodness does it look
cool I also have to say that one of my
favorite things to do with this is just
to go back and forth between the inpin
and anti-spin variations tracing out
only half of the path of this before
continuing on in either direction it's a
great way to build tension and really
mess with the audience highly
recommended all right so we've covered
basic flowers we've covered anti-spin
flowers we've covered fountains we've
covered body tracers so what is there
left to explore oh goodness get ready
for this one trick number five Advanced
Gunslinger flowers these are not just a
great challenge but probably one of my
favorite POI flowers of all time and I
love doing them Gunslinger flowers
involve so many different skills from
Gunslinger weaves to gunslinger waist
straps and then taking them into
Gunslinger flowers I will say I feel
like the anti-spin version of
Gunslingers is slightly easier than the
ins spin version but your mileage may
vary it was actually seeing Gunslinger
flowers being performed online that made
me want to learn how to do gun Slingers
in the first place and my goodness it
was such a rewarding Journey not only
did these tricks carry with them the
volume that we get out of flowers as
well as the cool intricate patterns that
we get out of the concentric circles but
also too performing them as Gunslingers
means that we have to be able to do them
quite fast and well that's electrifying
both for the audience as well as for the
performer and that's why they sit at the
top of the list as the most advanced
expression of flowers that I have yet
played with and hey if you're interested
in skill progression and more
specifically with performing those guns
Slinger flowers you should check out my
course on my learning site over at
learn. drexfactor docomo do Gunslingers
in that course you'll learn everything
from the basic entries and exits spiral
wraps weaves and yes even the Gunslinger
flowers and hybrids I'll leave a link to
that down in the description as well as
up in the cards check it out clearly
there are a lot of Po flowers out there
most of which did not make this list I'm
curious what are your favorites leave me
a comment and let me know also be sure
to like subscribe and share to help
other people find this video and help my
channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and if you out there are
enjoying watching these videos there's
an easy way that you can support them
and make it possible for me to make more
of them and that's to head on over to
patreon at patreon.com drexfactor pooy
and sign up there you can get access to
a whole host of awesome rewards and even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in sharing the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world so
go check that out please and thank you
and if you're hungry for checking out
more levels of poi difficulty you should
check out my five levels of Po stalls
I'll include a link to it down in the
description as well as up here on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today yourself and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace